le problème de toutes ses études c'est
que pour qu'elle puisse vouloir dire
quelque chose sur le protocole raul il
faut le respecter et c'est quoi le
protocole robe ces deux choses c'est un
associé la molécule de chloroquine à une
molécule d'antibiotiques premier point
et deuxième point c'est de donner aux
malades en première phase et non pas
dans une phase plus désespérés deuxième
phase grave ça ne marche pas donc voila
moi je vois qu'en france y compris on a
lancé des études clients tout fait pour
biaiser le résultat soit qu'elles
n'associez que la molécule du chlore
hocklines sans avoir les molécules
antibiotiques soient que est donné ce
traitement uniquement dans une deuxième
phase moi ce que je constate c'est que
george a disqualifié les travaux du
professeur certaines études je pense que
oui bien sûr et je pense que aujourd'hui
on meurt quatre fois moins marseille
alors est ce que c'est parce que
marseille il ya une météorologie spécial
mais ça c'est un chiffre voilà quand ce
professeur raoul publie des analyses sur
1000 patients on devrait vouloir s'en
inspirer finalement il ya deux écoles il
ya des gens qui disent valais sont
prescrire les médecins parce que on est
en situation de guerre on a une crise et
c'est l'empirisme qui commande puis
d'autres qui disent ah non c'est d'abord
la recherche médicale avec des règles
très méthodologique qu'il faut respecter
voilà bah je pense que quand on n'a pas
d'autre traitement qui fonctionne quand
on a une molécule qu'on connaît depuis
longtemps à condition que ce soit des
médecins qui la prescrivent je pense que
on doit faire un certain nombre
d'avancées dans le domaine et là aussi
je pense qu'on va prendre trop de retard